ps5 might be easier to get gotham
knight's got a new trailer and the last
fifa game is on the horizon
if you've been looking for a playstation
5 and haven't been able to get one well
2022 could finally be your year as part
of sony's latest investor briefing the
company said it projects to sell 18
million ps5 consoles during the fiscal
year that began april 1st and runs
through march 31st 2023 for comparison
sony sold 11.5 million ps5 consoles
during its fiscal year that ended on
march 31st 2022 and 7.8 million
playstation 5s for the fiscal year that
ended on march 31st 2021. the projection
of 18 million is based on sony's current
visibility into parts procurement which
could be a sign that the company
believes the chip shortage and other
supply issues might improve but even
though sony seems somewhat optimistic
about supply looking better the wider
consensus on general supply issues is
less positive as some in the wider
technology world believe shortages could
stretch into 2024 looking at the video
game space specifically nintendo said
during its earnings briefing this week
that there is no end in sight for the
ongoing chip shortage and just so we're
clear
it's not these type of chips
and since we're on the subject of
nintendo the company has confirmed that
bayonetta 3 is still scheduled for
launch in 2022 so hopefully that's a big
relief for some of you worried fans out
there and now let's talk about a game
that is not coming to switch at all
gotham knights to be fair the upcoming
superhero game was never coming to
nintendo's hybrid console to begin with
but now it's been confirmed that the
game is also skipping ps4 and xbox one
as well in a press release the
developers said it's aiming to provide
the best possible gameplay experience
using the more powerful hardware
available with ps5 series x and s and pc
alongside that release info fans also
got a new gameplay trailer this trailer
showcased how nightwing and red hood's
playstyles compare when tackling the
same mission solo as well as how they
can both complement one another if
playing gotham knights in two-player
co-op okay the next story is very
important if you don't want your
grandmother to go into game stop next
year and ask for the wrong game ea's
massively popular football soccer series
ea sports fifa is changing names as
rumored the franchise will be called ea
sports fc going forward as a part of a
rights negotiation process with fifa
that has been brewing for some time
already in a statement ea told fans
quote everything you love about the fifa
series will be a part of ea sports fc
this includes experiences modes leagues
tournaments clubs athletes as well as
ultimate team career mode pro clubs and
more ea may be losing the fifa name but
is retaining licensing from more than 19
000 players 700 plus teams 100 plus
stadiums and 30 leagues this year's game
will still be called fifa 23 because
ea's deal will remain in place for the
time being and ea's cam weber said this
year's game will be the most expansive
ever the first new game bearing the ea
sports fc name will be released in 2023
now hit the comment section let me know
your favorite brand of chips or crisps
depending on where you live i'll see you
tomorrow
you